[Music]  the high school is the foundation for  the rest of your life there's only one  chance and first impression work hard  put your heart out there and don't go  into high school without backup you need  to stick together to survive die one  last thing don't belong say high school  is an app for reinvention but I said  that  goodbye romance hello drama this should  be bunkers  [Music]  you'll teach Trump's victory compa I see  you and I'm down with it  I like the freaky  [Music]  what happened with sticking together you  don't understand this life it's my  destiny let's do it how are we gonna  survive high school  [Music]  please break down what's going on it's  complicated  we're dysfunctional understatement we  don't need luck  it's Brentwood nothing bad happens you  how about OJ no offense Jamal no I'm  good we don't claim him  [Music]